now welcome to the sylveon cling Brel
from france i am going to name in there
nope oops come on so we'll probably get
a no english opening not not now even
try to play in the style of them grand
prix attack still try to yes but there
is this this is so great here any white
can certainly play it but shouldn't be
anything but anything too special okay
night c4m this is in fact an IBM the
gaudi five if it probably will place
your form
okay that's not very comfortable make a
platform before I strong probably if I
cannot take because of Queen eh drive
okay this is probably also not not too
shabby but I if I was more afraid of I
had still it still still good okay but
watch what should I do I've removed the
90-foot 96 0 and e 2 I need to take yeah
and now after castles g6 shouldn't be
queen h5 I mean I can play g6 the
sacrifice is not so dangerous or in fact
I don't think dangerous at all yeah I'm
still okay here I had some doubts in the
opening earth maybe this eve or move
from one early or stronger okay what is
happening here he's attacking age seven
of course may be preparing work to you
one yeah so h6 would really weak in the
dark squares yeah I have a turn I still
prefer that to g6 when he has Bishop h6
with tempo and stuff
the Sun I don't think that this is so so
terrible for me I can maybe play here
Rock do you want some a move that can
can be quite annoying so try to play
against that yeah just just take that
and turn watch now
don't have a great square for the
Queen's as a slight slight problem but
check other than that sir it's quite
okay I didn't see that yeah sometimes
just as an awfully simple game you just
blunder porn and then it gets a very
very tricky okay maybe try to approach
the king yeah threatening group takes
you form a bishop f3 this would name me
as very strong what I don't think that
that you can do that simply yeah still
it's just just not good that you can
don't think so so let's see how to
punish this I can give this chick here
got queen here KO create probably hmm
yeah maybe it's just a draw maybe should
be five I can go wish of d5 and tending
Queen f3 as well hmm yeah Bishop a7s
Chester just amazingly cheeky the smooth
yeah Bishop t5 is got Queen III and I
don't don't don't see a win
I don't see win
guy you can try to play for win with
queen bee three but I cannot really
believe in that hmm maybe there is a win
somewhere but I don't see it
I don't see it
okay come on let's let's let's gamble
here I ok Quincy age is certainly to
play rupee eight you can try of course
something else upturn check yeah I cook
yeah then he's got this was checking
it's not really working
Queen h2 now is the threat
ok check
yeah I mean it's quite resigned I had
some threats and I don't think he can
play for William so a bit bit lucky it
probably should should be a draw okay
check so coming here okay you can play
age fault that's clear at it so far it's
a very very dangerous position computer
gives gives equal they're probably
there's some sort of Perpetual check
after h4 I can I can just take that this
is what I would have played it's
obviously super dangerous it's it's
really strange that he took on a 7
because this is completely unimportant
bond and a rupee for was really an
obvious threat and this is an
interesting position for for analysis
computer is not turn is giving black
here at the moment with my engine a very
slight edge slide edge for black just a
quite strange hard to say but I want to
change check quickly this position
before if there is yeah Bishop e7 is
just completely unnecessary you can play
any move white is just two pawns up here
I have have no compensation and this is
this is now really dangerous and quite
obviously you just play too quickly i
think then now here yeah here this is a
this is a draw probably this is
straightforward wrong question is do I
have something else I mean I thought
about rookie five but this is not really
threatening anything I don't threaten
Queen h2 because he's got this
interposing move all the time so this is
no way to to play I thought hope
and none in this position that this
could be an idea but 23 and he is
covering this critical square rupee
eight Queen somewhere maybe maybe so
uninteresting green here
hmm I don't know Black has compensation
for for the material but is it enough it
it's an exchange three pawns but the
computer only gives white one torn EDM
but the line it is giving us so it's
still pretty a pretty bleak for black
something something like like that and
where's the play for one what can do can
do that yeah pretty in your main just
yeah but in essence he simply shouldn't
take on a seven this makes it difficult
to check and if he does not blunder the
made here and play h4 yeah this is just
just a super complicated position Brooke
probably you should move the rook cannot
what does it have a check out so
probably something like that yet now the
instant idea would be to take but it's
it's this move jack so you cannot take
on g3
maybe this this allows after you see is
a teenage seven and now somewhere yeah
this is like walking on it on a rope
with no safety net king queen here
probably and this is a solo draw yeah
super difficult alright thanks for
watching